all right this is the day that you all
have been waiting for which is probably
not really that many people I don't
think anyone really asked for this but
I'm doing a GoPro Hero six vlog test
today
I've got Sara Beach hey guys Ron listen
Ron one Peachy and now we're gonna go
shoot a video for her channel yeah yeah
a good ol wide-angle now we're shooting
and wide do you want to shoot 30 did you
shoot 30 instead I did I'm not sure why
okay you're 24 you
[Music]
I'm making a return so you know I don't
even want to go through the story of why
I have two apple watches and why I have
to return them I'll tell you guys later
basically what happened is I got one I
wasn't sure which size I wasn't that I
decided that I wanted a different size
and then I got the wrong color and then
one of them ended up shipping do you
think it was gonna ship for like several
months right now New York is so good the
weather is not cold yet but it's like 70
so it's good it's gonna York is fabulous
the energy is always high very high
energy I'm still trying to get there to
move to more chuggy
that's babies baby steps baby get up it
won't happen you know what happened and
Nautilus I'm hosting Good Morning
America or something like that that's
the only way
[Music]
your turn has been very successful now
we're shooting a really fun video on
Sara's Channel I'm excited okay so we're
comparing the iPhone 8 portrait mode
with a DSLR and then we're going to get
people to guess which one is the iPhone
portrait mode picture this is going to
be good I'm excited I can't wait to see
what people think
[Music]
take the drone up this is a DJI Mavic by
far the best Road ever sorry we're
running on a right track
[Music]
we're testing it right now both of the
cameras so this is what I'm not okay
this is the hero 5 right here this is
the hero 6 right here they look the same
how's it look guys but the image
stabilization
yes it's letter in the six right is
definitely much that well I don't know
yeah I haven't tried it yet so we're
moving around a little let's see
walking normal walk this is des I'm not
normal walking right now I'm like I'm
bouncing around
here we go I'm gonna spin around a
little just because why not
it's a look it's a look it's a look now
we're gonna do a run test okay so I'm
running I'm running not I'm running
fairly fast okay let's see
I wonder how stable it is I don't know
now I'm jumping
we did not yet
now cam run some more
[Music]
today I am so excited and we're testing
out the GoPro Hero six still this is the
same flock so far up to this point I've
already edited but you've previously
seen I did this because I wanted to see
what it looked like so I'd be able to
like actually talk about what it looks
like in the video because usually when I
do these camera test videos I don't know
what the footage looks like so now we're
gonna go to Disney and let's test out
more of this optical image stabilization
not think about Space Mountain my sure
sense where are you and as I went
through security the guy goes where are
you I'm like I'm sorry what I know I
dude he was talking about I felt like
when I'm going back into the country or
going to another country when they start
quizzing you and asking you these
questions and I'm like I'm in trouble
yeah we're heading today I'm like oh my
god where am i heading I have no idea
[Music]
so strong
trying to figure out which one looks
better the denote II take a better photo
we're now walking around you're meeting
Adam hopefully very shortly see Jenna
already explained this in her vlog but
we only got a pass to Disneyland we can
only stay here for two hours and they're
in California Adventure I didn't know
well you got like the there's a thing
that you can get the max bus the app and
you can request Fast Pass you like the
app but all of them are available to
like tonight so a little late so now
we're just kind of like taking pictures
then walking around and playing on
social media you don't even get about
ice cream had a frog it was better like
the churro ice cream oh my gosh
delicious I know the town does nothing
still can see the world when it's
finished
[Music]
believe I need to blow it up on to new
Star Wars here it's all the shirts that
I have right now are all long-sleeve
star restaurants and bb-8 that is very
nice
now that's just okay this is incredible
how long we been waiting in line
for now
I was screaming the whole time at the
top
I am hey paper and your favorite store
the Star Wars store we are I'm so
excited I already picked out some things
that I want we need to now actually
picked a note I was watching
that is really so cute adorable he sings
a little song O'Berry makes got a kid
yeah bye guys I'm glad we got into you
it's always the best I gotta go check
out alright items oh yeah soon huh later
that brings me to clothes and if you
guys enjoy this next of the GoPro Hero
six cross my next video thank you can
you be in our video
[Music]
won't be breaking
I could make it even